Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question
de Solveil, qu'on va écouter :
« Comment c'était avant d'avoir
toute la nouvelle technologie? »
Merci Solveil pour ta question. Ça serait dur de dire
qu'il y a eu une vie avant les technologies,
parce qu'on avait des technologies quand même
chez les Premières Nations avant l'arrivée
des premiers Européens et ces technologies
ont quand même été reprises
par les premiers arrivants. Je pense aux canoës,
je pense aux kayaks, je pense à la raquette,
qui sont des technologies qui étaient
tellement bien adaptées à notre territoire
qu'on les utilise encore aujourd'hui.
Tout ce qui change, c'est les matériaux
et peut-être un peu l'apparence de la
raquette, justement, ou du canoë, du kayak.
Mais encore aujourd'hui, le modèle est le même.
Là, si on parle de technologie,
plus des technologies de communication,
par exemple, dans les communautés,
c'est extrêmement important.
Pourquoi? Parce qu'on est souvent
très éloignés les uns des autres.
On n'a parfois pas accès à la route.
Des fois, nos communautés sont tellement loin
qu'il faut prendre un avion pour pouvoir
se visiter les uns les autres.
Alors là, le téléphone, les médias sociaux,
la radio et la télévision sont des moyens
pour communiquer entre nous qui sont
extrêmement importants. Tellement, qu'il y a même
des grand-mamans qui ont des pages
de médias sociaux pour pouvoir voir
des photos de leurs petits-enfants qui sont
dans une autre communauté.
Donc, on utilise beaucoup les médias
et les réseaux sociaux, le téléphone, pour
pouvoir se parler. Mais, ça peut arriver
des fois, que certaines technologies
soient moins bonnes
en longue distance. Donc, on utilise encore
certaines des technologies qui sont
un peu plus vieilles, mais qui sont beaucoup
plus fiables, comme la radio. On a beaucoup
de radios communautaires dans chacune
des communautés, puisque ça peut servir
à tout : à dire « Rentre chez vous,
ta maman te cherche. » ou « On va faire un souper
communautaire ce soir. »
Mais les technologies, c'est certain que tout
ce qui peut améliorer la vie
des Premières Nations va être utilisé.
C'est pour ça qu'on a adopté le métal,
qu'on a adopté le verre. Des choses
qui n'existaient pas avant l'arrivée
des Européens et qui ont servi à améliorer
la vie des Premières Nations.
Donc, si ça peut améliorer la vie, et pas
nous faire marcher de même tout le temps,
c'est certain qu'on va prendre ces
technologies-là et qu'on va
les adapter à nos cultures.
Donc, je te remercie beaucoup
pour ta question. J'espère que j'ai pu
y répondre et j'espère que vous allez nous
en envoyer d'autres. N'hésitez pas,
surtout, à partager les vidéos.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine.